[Musique]
m
c'est noël
alors vous avez peut-être trouver des
cadeaux pour tous les gens que vous
connaissez mais est-ce que vous allez
trouver un cadeau pour les gens que vous
connaissez pas et qu'on nous vraiment
méchant vraiment besoin et sans que ça
vous coûte 1 euro
[Musique]
je vous propose là c'est de vous
inscrire sur le registre national des
donneurs de moelle osseuse et
potentiellement de sauver la vie de
quelqu'un
vos cadeaux dans l'immédiat ça vous
prendra deux trois minutes max le temps
de vous pré inscrire en ligne et pour la
suite
bah je vais vous raconter ça ce qu'on va
faire c'est qu'on a commencé dans la
junte avant d'enfiler vos costumes de
père et de mère noël vous vous demandez
peut-être qui a besoin de votre moelle
osseuse qui a besoin de votre cadeau eh
ben les greffes de moelle osseuse ça
concerne les personnes atteintes de
maladies graves du sang vous connaissez
peut-être la leucémie par exemple c'est
un très bon exemple parce que ça
représente 80% des personnes concernées
alors oui j'ai bien dit moelle osseuse
un pas moi lépine hier lorsque je
comprends que ça puisse vous faire
fuiter mais c'est promis personne va
toucher à votre moelle épinière
c'est pas du tout par là que ça se passe
personne ne va venir vous piquer votre
sa morale ni votre second co sais pas
s'il y en avait deux trois ans non on
est bien d'accord
on parle de la moelle osseuse celle
qu'on a à l'intérieur des eaux pas de la
colonne vertébrale rien à voir là c'est
une substance qui fabrique des cellules
qui elle-même fabrique les cellules de
notre sens et dans certaines maladies
graves comme la leucémie par exemple
mais il y en ad'autres va elle fait pas
son travail correctement et c'est
embêtant parce que les cellules de notre
sens elles sont super utile il ya les
globules blancs qui font partie de notre
système immunitaire et qui luttent
contre les infections les globules
rouges qui transportent l'oxygène
jusqu'à nos organes et les plaquettes
qui jouent un rôle dans la coagulation
et qui sont les premières à rentrer en
action pour arrêter un saignement donc
l'idée c'est de greffe et de la moelle
osseuse qui marche si vous voulez pour
que tout ça soit bien fabriqué au final
mais le problème c'est qu'on peut pas
prendre la moelle de n'importe qui il
faut que la personne qui donne et la
personne qui va recevoir soit compatible
pas il faut que leur moelle soient
compatibles c'est à dire qu'elles se
ressemblent le plus possible sinon le
corps du receveur va la rejeter
du coup quand quelqu'un a besoin d'une
greffe on commence par chercher ce qu'il
a des frères ou des soeurs qui sont
compatibles mais dans les deux tiers des
cas on trouve pas donc on cherche au
niveau des autres gens c'est à dire vous
moi sauf que bon si vous avez besoin
d'une greffe et que vous venez me
demander à moi il ya les services et là
il ya une chance sur un million pour que
vous et moi on soit compatible donc
voyez chercher comme ça au pif
ça peut prendre du temps et du temps
dans ces cas là le malade on n'a pas
beaucoup
du coup l'idée c'est d'avoir des listes
par pays et au niveau international avec
tous les profils de compatibilité des
gens inscrits comme donneur comme ça en
cas de besoin on rentre le profil du
malade et ça nous sort la liste des ou
du donneur compatible
il ya plus qu à le contacter oui parce
que le problème c'est que la moelle
osseuse ça se conserve pas donc il faut
la prélever et l'envoyer direct aux
malades pour la greffe et dans les
heures qui suivent du coup concrètement
pour faire un joli cadeau
voilà comment ça se passe vous vous
inscrivez en ligne je vous mets le lien
dans la description juste je vous
préviens faut avoir entre 18 et 50 ans
on vous fait venir pour un examen
médical pour voir si vous pouvez donner
et pour une prise de sang qui va
déterminer votre profil de compatibilité
est juste une prise de sang rien de plus
ensuite vous attendez si un jour il ya
un malades en attente de greffe et que
vous êtes compatibles on vous appelle
vous revenez voir le médecin et on vous
refait une prise de sang pour préciser
un peu les choses et pour voir si vous
êtes en bonne santé et si tout est ok
bah on cale la date du prélèvement alors
le prélèvement comment ça se passe il ya
deux options et c'est le médecin qui va
choisir la meilleure option pour le
patient qui doit recevoir à gré la
première c'est de prélever les cellules
de moelle osseuse qui circulent dans
votre sens on vous fait des petites
piqûres sous la peau quelques jours
avant pour stimuler tout ça et le jour j
on prélève votre sens on le fait passer
dans une machine qui sépare les éléments
dont on
- équivaut réinjecte ce dont on n'a pas
besoin
c'est la méthode la plus courante c'est
à peu près les trois quarts des cas
donc là vous avez juste à remonter votre
manche ou à porter un pull de noël moche
avec une manche thomas gottin la
deuxième c'est de prélever sa à la
source donc au niveau de l'os on fait ça
au niveau du bassin sous anesthésie
générale
la ponction en elle-même c'est rapide
c'est sans danger c'est peu voire pas
douloureux mais il faut rester à
l'hôpital de jour en tout dans tous les
cas une fois que le prélèvement a été
fait il part directement à l'hôpital du
receveur et on lui injecte par perfusion
donc vous voyez c'est simple ça peut
vraiment sauver une vie et si ça se
trouve en ce moment même il ya quelqu'un
qui attend une greffe et qui est
compatible avec vous mais attention
évidemment c'est une décision qui mérite
qu'on y réfléchisse donc juste pensez-y
d'ailleurs deux ou trois trucs à savoir
avant de vous décider mais là on va pas
vous appelez tous les quatre matins moi
je suis inscrit sur la liste depuis des
années on va appeler deux fois sans que
cela débouche sur un prélèvement
si un jour on trouve un malade
compatible avec vous ce sera la seule
fois de votre vous que vous donnerez
votre moyen de choisir
sauf si le même malade a besoin d'une
autre grève plus tard ou si il ya un
membre de votre famille avec qui vous
est compatible et qui a aussi besoin
d'une vraie vous êtes inscrits jusqu'à
vos 60 ans et si vous voulez être
retirés des listes avant vous pouvez
demander à n'importe quel moment sans
avoir à vous justifier en quatre
éléments tout est organisé au moins un
mois al avance et on vous donne les
papiers qu'il faut pour que votre boss
vous libère et évidemment tout est pris
en charge y compris la perte de salaire
éventuel ok mais alors vous allez
peut-être me demander mais pourquoi moi
je vais aller faire un cadeau à
quelqu'un que je connais pas alors je
vous répondre déjà parce que ça fait de
vous quelqu'un de bien vous pouvez
sauver une vie facilement
en plus si ça suffit pas on peut prendre
la chose dans l'autre sens plus il ya de
gens inscrits sur le registre des
donneurs
moelle osseuse plus il ya de chances
d'en trouver incompatible avec vous si
un jour vous en avez besoin vous ou un
de vos proches
voilà dtc c'est fini pour aujourd'hui je
vous souhaite un joyeux noël penser à
tout ça on se retrouve très vite pour de
nouvelles vidéos
d'ici là prenez soin de vous prenez soin
des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout pour que
vous bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]